go to eric in jackson mississippi eric
what's going on
how you doing ken man i am living the
dream how are you sir
i'm doing good how you guys doing today
we are doing outstanding look
what's up man how can we help okay look
the question i have i have a dilemma i
um i have about six thousand dollars
that i have
uh saved up and i need to fed towards my
debt
i only have two debts which are about
five thousand dollars in credit cards
and i have an auto loan which i owe
about thirty nine hundred dollars on
i was wanting to know which way do you
think i should go with the six thousand
uh you know as far as going to pay these
debts off
that's a great question dude
congratulations you're almost there
brother that's awesome
so you got six thousand bucks hey man
hey and you know what you get to the
finish line and you turn that corner of
that marathon and you just see that
that finish line it's just one mile
right and you start stumbling and
smiling and drooling you're almost there
man
all right so just keep following the
baby steps
so you said you've got a five thousand
dollar credit card and a would you say
3900
auto loan yes sir yes sir all right so
before today is over i want you to take
3 900 bucks of that
6 000 and that car is going to be yours
and nobody else's
today okay and then you're going to take
the rest of that dump that over the
credit card
keep it make sure you got that thousand
bucks in your emergency fund
um and then you are gonna just scratch
and claw and get the rest of that credit
card done and then you're gonna call
this show back
or you're gonna come down here and visit
us and we're gonna do your debt-free
scream right here in the lobby
is that cool yes sir you got that eric
so here's the deal
you got six k you got six thousand in
savings you're gonna you're gonna keep a
thousand dollars in the savings all
right
and then five goes to the 3 900 right
you're gonna wipe that out that leaves
1100 all right i got my shoes off so i
can count that high okay
and so we take the 1100 and you put it
into the 5 000
on the credit card and now we are
starting to cook
now you got 3 900 left and then you're
attacking this thing man
how long have you been on this journey
eric about to be honest man about a year
and a half now
you're so close how much you paid off
watching you guys man i had about 33 000
all together
eric now this might be worth a trip to
nashville to stand on that debt-free
stage over there
and uh we won't know who's hosting that
day but you need to do that you need to
consider that
man look that that's that's really a
part of the journey man it's
really a big piece that i think i'll be
missing man i think so
jackson mississippi is not that far away
yeah you can drive here
we can't wait but not at all not at all
all right so by the end of today you own
that car outright and then you are
just throwing everything you've got left
and not even into
today i mean let's put him on hold and
start start writing checks
dirk exactly don't even hang out what
are we waiting on there's there's 47
minutes in this hour
it needs to be before the hour is out i
love it pay this stuff
off that's exciting he's going to have 3
900 left
he's going to knock that out fast that's
huge i remember
that last little yeah little
construction paper chain we had left
this is how romantic i am ken when my
wife and i were going through this we
had
six figures in our debt and we created
one of those
construction paper chains and i'm so
romantic i hung it in our lit in our
bedroom
i never wanted to to not see it
and man did not make for great bedroom
decor but it made for every morning you
wake up and you see it and every night
you go to sleep and you see it it made
me a little bit
nuts but i remember that last chain and
just sat there and stared at us because
it was a big one right but finally
getting that thing done
it's fun did you did you rip it off the
wall i mean was there was that what was
the
no it was a little bit dramatic i this
is gonna shock the listeners i could be
a little bit messy that's why i
set you up on this one no it was a slow
pulled the tack out gently
my heart beat it felt a little hallmarky
my wife rolled her eyes and just walked
in there nothing about that was romantic
or hallmarky you kept saying romantic
romantic and it just felt like crafts
hearts and crabs
music actually did swell but in my heart
it did and it just came louder and
there was no confetti or nothing my
wife's like cool hey make sure when you
go to the store get somebody
it was kind of like yeah i was excited
that's the kind of free advice you get
on this show baby this is the ramsey
show